[Music]
is
germany
is
thank you very much mr president
mr president
excellencies
i want to reaffirm
what i expressed this morning
in the meeting of the general assembly
but of course it wouldn't make any sense
to bother you reading again the same
texts
that i'm sure you are all aware of
in between during the day
a number of events took place
and with your permission mr president
i would like to ask miss rosemary
dicarlo
to be able to brief you on those events
but simultaneously
the day was full of rumors
and indications
that
a
of an offensive
against the ukraine
was
imminent
in the recent past there were several
situations
with similar
indications
similar rumors
and i never believed in them
convinced that nothing serious
would happen
i was wrong
and i would like not to be wrong again
today
so
if indeed
an operation is being prepared
i have only one thing to say
from the bottom of my heart
president putin
stop your troops from attacking the
ukraine
give peace a chance
too many people have already died
thank you mr president
i thank the secretary general for his
introductory remarks
yes
and i now give the floor to
mr rose
thank you mr president
earlier today
the so-called authorities of the donetsk
and luhansk people's republics requested
military assistance from the russian
federation
also today the ukrainian authorities
declared a nationwide state of emergency
and announced other related defense and
security measures
including the mobilization of reservists
throughout the day we've seen disturbing
reports of continued heavy shelling
across the contact line and civilian and
military casualties
there are also reports of the repeated
targeting of civilian infrastructure
this evening different media
are carrying reports
of an ongoing large-scale military
buildup and on military columns moving
towards ukraine
the russian federation has also
reportedly shut airspace
to civilian aircraft near the border
with ukraine
the united nations cannot verify any of
these reports
but if these developments were confirmed
they would greatly aggravate an already
dangerous situation
the ukrainian authorities are also
reporting
a new large-scale cyber attack targeting
several state and financial institutions
mr president president zielinski earlier
this evening
called for continued diplomacy
separately
president putin also spoke about his
continued readiness to engage in
dialogue
we encourage such efforts even at this
late hour
un staff remain on the ground to provide
humanitarian assistance to the people of
ukraine
we are committed to staying and
delivering
all parties must ensure their safety and
security
respect for international humanitarian
law and international human rights law
is also paramount
we cannot predict exactly what will
happen in the coming hours and days in
ukraine
what is clear is the unacceptably high
cost in human suffering and destruction
of an escalation
the people of ukraine want peace
and i'm certain the people of russia
want peace
we must do everything in our power to
ensure that peace prevails thank you mr
president
mr carlos for her briefing
those council members who wish
thank you mr president
dear colleagues
this is the fourth time the council
is meeting in ukraine in a matter of
weeks
every time we meet reality on the ground
confirms bit by bit what some of us have
been anticipating
russia has been saying one thing
and doing its country
we were told troops were retreating when
they only have increased
we were told to stop hysteria since
troops were in russian territory no
longer they are invading a neighbor
unprovoked with false protests false
narratives and fabricated news
every development unfolding in the last
48 hours confirms to us and to the world
that russian wars have nothing to do
with with its security
that its anxieties are not linked to
nato enlargement
that this issue is not a confrontation
between russia and the west
this is a confrontation between russia
and international law
the u.n charter that it deliberately has
chosen to ignore
a confrontation between a hegemonistic
vision
and the rules-based world order
dear colleagues
it's not about russia's concern
it's about russia's appetite
the ukrainians are facing another
aggression just because they dare to
exist
because they have chosen to be
independent because they have opted for
democracy
dear colleagues
this is a dark hour not only for ukraine
but for the entire international
community as we witness with trepidation
the progression of a pure act of
aggression carefully planned and
cold-bloodedly being executed
we called and hoped for a back down of
the russian federation from this
senseless destructive
and self-destructive action
we repeat the same call for russia to
stop
to reflect
to reverse its illegal decisions
to withdraw from this senseless madness
to de-escalate
not to push towards precipice
several mechanisms are in place and
various proposals have been made
including by president zielenski whose
calls remain unanswered
diplomacy is like hope it dies lost but
for it to work it must be seized not
ignored as the secretary general just
called for here
we call on the fellow members of the
security council to rally in support of
ukraine's sovereignty and territorial
integrity russia has been warned
repeatedly
that they will be alone in this
foolishness
that they will be responsible for the
innocent lives lost including russians
maybe
and for the destruction caused in the
heart of europe in the 21st century
if they choose to continue to execute
their plans as everything indicates
they will bear not only the consequences
of the war but also the historical blame
and shame of invading a neighboring
country on its responsibility as a big
country as a permanent member of the
security council
calls for it to work and help preserve
peace and security not to torpedo it
we reiterate our support to ukraine's
sovereignty and territorial integrity
within its internationally organized
borders and territorial waters
in concluding i welcome the presence of
the permanent representative of ukraine
to this meeting i would like to convey
to him to the ukrainian government and
people that at this
most critical moment in their history
they are not alone and we stand firm in
full solidarity with them for their
rights to free to be free and choose who
they want to be
i thank you
thank you mr president
and thank you secretary general
thank you for your strong strong stance
and your powerful remarks today at the
general assembly
and for your remarks tonight
colleagues a few moments ago i spoke to
president biden who asked me to convey
in the strongest possible terms
his
and our steadfast support for ukraine
and support for the urgent meeting this
council has convened tonight
furthermore he asked me to share that
the united states and our allies and
partners will continue to respond to
russia's actions with unity
with clarity
and with conviction
we are here tonight
because we believe along with ukraine
that a full-scale
further invasion into ukraine by russia
is imminent
tonight we're seeing the russians close
airspace
move troops into donbass
and move forces into combat ready
positions
this is a perilous moment
and we're here for one reason and one
reason only
to ask russia to stop
return to your borders send your troops
and your tanks and your planes
back to their barracks and hangars
and send your diplomats
to the negotiating table
back away from the brink before it is
too late
last week the united states informed
this council and the world about what we
expected to see unfold
we said that russia would manufacture or
pretext for an attack
we have since seen numerous false flag
events staged along the line of line of
lines of contact in donbass
we said russia would theatrically
convene emergency meetings at the
highest levels of the russian government
we all saw this on monday with the state
televised security council meeting held
by president putin an orchestrated
moment in which the russian government
decided to recognize
as and i quote independent states
unquote
sovereign territory of ukraine
controlled by russia's proxies since
2014.
they literally violated ukraine's
sovereignty and territorial integrity on
live television before the world
we said that false proclamations would
come declaring russia would need to
defend russian speakers in ukraine
we got that and much more from president
putin's speech on monday
and during the speech of the russian
ambassador in the general assembly today
no one could have predicted just how
dangerous inciting and far-reaching
president putin's speech would be
with putin arguing
for taking the world back in time to an
era of empires and colonies
finally we said the attack would come
next
that we could expect communications to
be jammed cyber attacks to shut down key
ukrainian institutions
last week we attributed to russia denial
of service attacks against ukrainian
banks and we saw similar activity this
morning targeting government sites as
well
and in the last few hours we have
received very concerning reports of
destructive malware where placed on
hundreds of computers and executed
on at least some
after that we said would come the bombs
and missiles the soldiers and the tanks
already soldiers have been deployed to
the occupied region of ukraine
ladies and gentlemen we are here tonight
because we believe the rest is imminent
now over the past few weeks russia has
called
our predictions hysterical
russia said we were lying russia said we
were supplying the world with
misinformation
russia's diplomats even laughed in the
face of the human suffering we were
sounding the alarm about
but what we said would happen has come
to pass
for all the world to see
so let us be clear
all parties are not
culpable here
there's no middle ground
calling for both sides to de-escalate
only gives russia a pass
russia
is the aggressor here
russia's attack on ukraine
is tantamount to an attack on the u.n
and every member state in the chamber
tonight
the security council is charged with
adjudicating threats to peace and
security
russia is bypassing
its entirely
russia is bypassing it entirely and
taking matters into its own hands
and that undermines the institution
it undermines everyone who participates
in it
the united states ukraine its allies and
partners across europe
u.n officials every other member of this
security council
we have all repeatedly implored russia
to engage at the diplomatic table
those calls were not heard
instead tonight
russia has brought its people the
ukrainian people and the world
to the brink of a conflict that will
produce an untold amount of human
suffering
i said it in the general assembly this
morning and i'll say it again tonight
every day russians should be asking
themselves right now
how many russian lives
putin will sacrifice for his cynical
ambitions
responsible members of this security
council will stand together
and we will stand with ukraine
and we will we will do so despite a
reckless irresponsible permanent member
of the security council abusing its
powers to attack its neighbor and
subvert the u.n
and our international system
this morning in the general assembly
we saw dozens of leaders from across the
globe
stand up to defend the u.n charter and
ukraine against russia's brazen attacks
we were proud to stand with them
today i had the opportunity to meet with
ukrainian foreign minister kulaiba
and many of you were in the general
assembly hall this morning when foreign
minister kaleiba received enthusiastic
and overwhelming applause after his
remarks
since he could not be here this evening
i would like to conclude
by echoing his words
this morning he warned us all that quote
no one will be able to sit out this
crisis if president putin decides that
he can move forward
with this aggression against ukraine
your governments and your people will
face painful consequences together with
our government and our people unquote
he is right
history tells us that
and we must confront this threat head-on
in this council in the u.n and in our
capitals
the people of ukraine are counting on us
let's not let them down thank you mr
president
of the united states
of the united kingdom
mr president i thank the secretary
general and under secretary general de
carlo for their remarks
we are here tonight
to call on russia to avert
war for months
russia has been holding a gun to
ukraine's head
now
president putin's finger
is on the trigger
a full-scale conflict
in a country of 44 million people
will bring immense suffering
casualties on both sides
and devastating humanitarian
consequences
the members of this council
the general assembly
and the secretary general
have all called this week
for respect for the principles of the un
charter
the world
is calling for peace
but russia
is not listening
mr president
make no mistake
the uk
will not compromise
we will not compromise our commitment to
ukraine's sovereignty and territorial
integrity
our support
for peace
prosperity
and the democratic freedom of the people
of ukraine
we will not compromise our commitment
to the purpose and principles
of the un charter
above all
the founding principle of this united
nations
that we live together in peace
with one another as good neighbors
russia's actions
are
an assault on the charter
and we will not compromise
our commitment
to a search for peace
we're here for the second time this week
in the council
my prime minister and foreign and
defense secretaries have been unsparing
in their diplomatic efforts
but we have also announced
a significant further sanctioned step
against russia
with our allies a package targeted
against some of the russian oligarchs
banks
and politicians
supporting president putin
and we will ratchet up economic
consequences
should russia continue its aggression
there is still time
for restraint
reason
and de-escalation
but that time is now
thank you
for her statement
representative of france
foreign
to peace and security in
by recognizing the independence of
portions of ukraine
faced with a strategy
has demonstrated
not resort to violence despite that
i wish to reiterate our subsidiary
we're the people of ukraine
president
reminded him of
of the russian president
peace
russians
it is that of respect to the charter of
the united nations
call each of the members of this council
to act responsibility
and to reserve your support
initiatives
to violations
of ireland
thank you mr president and i'd like to
thank the secretary general and under
secretary general de carlo for their
very sobering remarks
at the beginning of our meeting
mr president tonight as we gather at
this table we are staring into the abyss
of a major conflict in europe
a conflict that would have major global
implications
tonight
the core principles of this united
nations in which we believe
are under attack
in ireland we know the importance of the
rules-based international order
we know the importance of respecting the
voice and integrity of all countries
big or small
most fundamentally
we know the value of peace
we believe that one state threatening
and using lethal force against another
to get its way or to expand its
territory is no solution
ireland has a deep understanding
informed by our history that dialogue
and respect resolved disputes
tonight this drives our solidarity with
ukraine
it is our collective responsibility
indeed our obligation here at this table
to maintain international peace and
security
nothing less
that means
we stand up for the sovereignty and
territorial integrity of every member
state of the united nations
let's be clear
the internationally recognized borders
of ukraine have not changed
the decision by russia to recognize as
independent entities the
non-government-controlled areas of
donetsk and luhansk regions of ukraine
does not change those borders one iota
they did not change in 2014
and they have not changed this week
we urge the russian federation to
reverse this decision immediately
we urge the russian federation to
refrain from further escalatory
unilateral actions which can only serve
to further deepen this crisis
tonight
the path for diplomacy the path for
dialogue that we have called on for so
long
is perishly narrow
the principles of the un charter we hold
dear
have already been breached
these principles now risk being further
violated
this is the time to show courage
the courage and the time now to pull
back from the precipice
the time to return to dialogue and
diplomacy
the use of military aggression has no
place in our modern world
have we learned absolutely nothing from
our history
these united nations rose from the ashes
of two world wars the senseless
destruction of that era was born of a
belief that military might makes right
this philosophy applied with modern
weaponry would unleash devastation and
human suffering affecting millions of
innocent people
tonight
we stand with the people of ukraine
tonight we stand with the un charter
we stand with those who even in this
dark hour still have the courage and
hope to bring us back from this
precipice
a resort to military conquest
for one state to impose its will
unilaterally against another
to annex part of its territory has
absolutely no place in the 21st century
there is still a choice
a choice to turn from the path of war to
the path of diplomacy and dialogue
mr president it is never too late to
make the right choice
thank you
i thank the representative of ireland
thank you mr president
let me begin by thanking secretary
general for his briefing on the evolving
situation in the eastern regions of
ukraine
the security council had met two days
ago and discussed the situation
we had called for urgent de-escalation
of tensions
and emphasized on sustained and focused
diplomacy to address all issues
concerning the situation
however
we note with regret that the calls of
the international community to give time
to the recent initiatives undertaken by
parties to diffuse tensions were not
heeded too
the situation is in danger of spiraling
into a major crisis
we express our deep concern over the
developments which if not handled
carefully may well undermine the peace
and security of the region
we call for immediate de-escalation and
for refraining from any further action
that could contribute to a worsening of
the situation
we call on all parties to exert greater
efforts to bridge divergent interests
i would like to underline that the
legitimate security interests of all
parties should be fully taken into
account
india has consistently advocated at the
united nations the need for peaceful
settlement of disputes in accordance
with international law
and with agreements entered into by
parties concerned
i underline once again that more than 20
000 indian nationals including students
are located in different parts of
ukraine including in its border areas
we are facilitating the return of all
indian nationals including students as
may be required
we believe that the solution lies in
sustained diplomatic dialogue between
the concerned parties in the meantime we
strongly emphasize the vital need for
all sides to maintain international
peace and security by exercising the
utmost restraint i thank you
i thank the representative of india for
his statement and i now give the floor
to the representative of the united arab
um
[Music]
particularly
is
is
thank you
i thank the secretary general and usg
rosemary de carlo for their important
statement
we are facing the dire prospect of a
major war in europe
norway strongly condemns the decision by
president putin
to send russian troops into donetsk and
luhansk regions
and the latest announcements of special
military operation
these decisions are unjustified
unprovoked and irresponsible
we call on russia to reverse these
decisions and to immediately completely
and unconditionally withdraw all its
military forces from the territory of
ukraine and
in the
vicinity of its internationally
recognized borders
our thoughts are with those who have
already suffered too much due to this
conflict
and with all those who are afraid that
tomorrow will be a lot worse
we call upon all parties to strictly
respect the relevant provisions of
international humanitarian law which
calls on the protection of civilians
including humanitarian personnel and
civilian infrastructure and to
facilitate safe rapid and unhindered
humanitarian access to those in need in
ukraine
like the secretary general clearly
stated the decision of the russian
federation to recognize the so-called
independent of donetsk and luhansk
regions are violation of the territorial
integrity and sovereignty of ukraine and
are inconsistent with the principles of
the charter of the united nations
let me recall the principles and
purposes of the u.n charter wisdom which
are now under threat
the charter applies to all nations
including russia
today in the general assembly member
states from all over the world strongly
urged the parties to pursue negotiation
towards a peaceful resolution of the
conflict with respect for international
law and ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial integrity
norway urges russia as a party to the
minsk agreement and to the conflict
to fulfill its commitments to abide by
international law and to return to the
path of diplomacy
russia has taken on a clear commitment
to seek a peaceful settlement to this
conflict and must honor it
we commend ukraine's posture of
restraint in the face of continued
provocation and destabilization effort
president let me conclude by again
reiterating novice and wavering support
for ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial integrity within its
international recognized borders thank
you
i thank the representative of norway for
her statement
to the representative
is that a critical juncture
china
we believe
historical context
and that the current situation is the
result of the interplay of many factors
china's position of safeguarding the
sovereignty and territorial integrity of
all states
sure
and address each other's legitimate
security concerns
china will continue to promote peace
talks in its own ways and welcomes and
encourages all efforts aimed at a
diplomatic solution thank you mr
president
i thank the representative of china for
his statement
of brazil
thank you mr president
i would like to thank the secretary
general and under secretary general
rosemary dicarlo
for the information and remarks they
have put before the council tonight
mr president the reports received about
the movement of troops into certain
areas of donetsk and luhansk in ukraine
are cause for extreme concern
the threat or use of force against the
territorial integrity
sovereignty and political independence
of a un member state is unacceptable
in the present circumstances the
security council must act according to
its main purpose
as holder of the primary responsibility
under the united nations charter for the
maintenance of international peace
and security
in the exercise of this responsibility
its actions
must be geared towards reduction
intentions
towards assisting parties in their
negotiations this is our primary role
the recourse to arms and confrontation
cannot lead to lasting peace
in that regard we call on all parties to
exercise maximum restraint
and refrain from any action that may
further increase tensions on the ground
the time is not for
belligerent rhetoric
nor for military threats but to engage
truly in a diplomatic process
the means of negotiation have not been
exhausted
immediate de-escalation is of high order
it means among others
complete and unconditional withdrawal of
all military forces as an effective
measure for the prevention and removal
of threats to peace
parties must abide by the terms of the
minsk agreements
above all by its call for a
comprehensive ceasefire
the monitoring mission of the osce
can assist if granted unrestrained
access in order to verify
identify and report accordingly any
violation of the ceasefire
furthermore the parties must allow the
rapid safe and unhindered access
unhindered access of humanitarian
assistance to those in need
the protection of civilians
including humanitarian personnel and
persons in vulnerable situations
must be respected unconditionally
we redouble our calls for the parties to
work constructively in all relevant
instances
such as the normandy format and the
trilateral contact group
negotiations must be mindful of the
principles of the un charter including
sovereignty independence
unity and territory would be aided by
our listening to the secretary general
and utilizing his good offices to
deliver according to their intended
design
in the coming days
we hope that we will observe the
escalation in donbass
and that every effort will be made to
protect the sovereignty territorial
integrity and political independence of
ukraine
we further hope that we will benefit
from the visionary leadership that the
world needs today
in committing to negotiating a lasting
european security architecture that
lowers perceptions of threat and
promotes cooperation i thank you
i thank the representative for his
statement
to the representative
for the information
this evening
of ukraine
leading to a massive exodus yeah
the united nations
and it's
my country is attached to the territory
of integrity
is the basis of our social contract as
members of the international community
we are persuaded
same fundamental principles of the
children of the united states
today
which we thought
unfortunately
in several regions in brazil in asia
integrity we call foreign
mexico
have increased
for this reason
once again
having ratified the charge
committed ourselves
peace
all of the secretary
the invasion of one country
since it is
we recall once again
a few days ago
in this very chamber
international community
made an emphatic declaration
depression
solution foreign the only way of drawing
away from the precipice which would be a
war in europe thank you very much sir
yeah
thank the representative of
i shall now make a mexico
in my capacity as the representative of
the russian federation
colleagues today we've had an intensive
day from the point of view of
discussions of the ukrainian crisis
repeat
benediction of their western sponsors
they will be able to achieve a military
solution to the problem
otherwise it is difficult to explain the
substantial intensification of shelling
and acts of diversity on the territory
of these reforms
recorded today almost 2 000 cases of
violations of the cease-fire regime
including almost one and a half thousand
explosions
those living in donetsk
are still sheltering in basements
repeating the ukrainian fairy tales that
those living in donetsk are all but
shelling themselves it is no surprise
that the increasing suffering of those
living in the donbass does not seem to
affect our western colleagues
today at the general assembly you
haven't been able to find one word of
compassion or condolences
presenting
yesterday
hear this and you don't want to hear it
now
there was ridiculous those living
underground
in a geopolitical game focused on
weakening russia
and promoting the uh blocker from nature
these people are women children the
elderly who for eight years have been
cowering from ukraine
these are ukraine people
and not the modern authorities
this is the difference in our oppression
if you
simply
its obligations under the mink's package
of measures
last week even there was a hope that
kiev would rethink
and nevertheless
to do in 2015
as much
uh
is
um
of distinguished members of the security
council
secretary general
under secretary
before i try to deliver parts of the
statement that i came here with tonight
most of it is already useless
since
10 p.m new york time
i would like to cite
article 4 of the u.n charter
and it says
membership in the united nations is open
to all
other peace-loving states
which accept the obligations contained
in the present charter
and in the judgment of the organization
are able and willing
to carry out these obligations
russia is not able
to carry out any of the obligations
the ambassador of the russian federation
three minutes ago
confirmed that his president declared
a war on my country
so before i read parts of my statement
i would like to avail of the presence of
the secretary general and request the
secretary general
to distribute among the members of the
security council
and the members of the general assembly
the legal memos
by the legal counsel
of the united nations dated december
1991
and in particular the legal memo dated
19th of december 1991.
the one that we've been trying to get
out of the secretariat for
a very long time and we were denied to
get it
the article for paragraph two of the
charter
reads
the admission of any such state to
membership in the united nations will be
affected
by a decision of the general assembly
upon the recommendation of the security
council mr secretary general please
instruct the secretariat
to distribute among the members of the
security council and the members to the
general assembly
a decision by the
security council dated december 1991
that recommends
that the russian federation
can be a member of this organization
as well as a decision by the general
assembly dated december 1991
where general assembly welcomes the
russian federation
to this organization
it would be a miracle if the secretariat
is able to produce
such decisions
there is nothing in the charter of the
united nations about continuity
as a sneaky way to get into the
organization
so when i was coming here
an hour ago so
i was intending to ask the russian
ambassador to confirm
on the record
that the russian troops will not start
firing
at ukrainians today
and go ahead with the offensive it
became useless
48 minutes ago
because about 48 minutes ago your
president declared the war on ukraine
so now i would like to ask the
ambassador of the russian federation to
say on the record
that at this very moment
your troops do not shall and bomb
ukrainian cities
that your troops do not move in the
territory of ukraine
you have a smartphone you can call
lavrov right now
we can make a pause to let you go out
and call him
if you are not in a position
to give an affirmative answer
the russian federation ought to
relinquish
responsibilities
of the president of the security council
pass these responsibilities onto a
legitimate member of security council
a member that is respectful of the
charter
and i ask the members of security
council to convene an emergency meeting
immediately
and consider
all necessary drought decisions
to stop the war
because it's too late my dear colleagues
to speak about the escalation too late
the russian president declared the war
on the record should i play the video of
your president
ambassador shall i do that right now or
you can't confirm it
do not interrupt me please thank you
then don't ask me questions when you are
speaking proceed with this proceed with
your state anyway you declare the war it
is responsibility of this body to stop
the war
so i call on every one of you
to do everything possible to stop the
war
or i should i play the video with your
president declaring the wall
thank you very much
[Music]
is
[Music]
i now give the floor to the
representative of
germany mr president we meet at the very
moment of a military escalation we have
not experienced in europe for over a
generation's time
the president of the russian federation
announced a military operation on
ukrainian territory
we condemn this in the strongest
possible terms
and we call upon all members of the
security council and the united nations
to now stand up for ukraine
and again against a shameless breach of
international law
two days ago russia's decision to
recognize the self-proclaimed so-called
people's republics of donyatsk and
luchansk
was harshly rejected in this council
it had already dealt a devastating blow
to the principles and the international
order that the united nations stand for
russia has not listened
and
it turns out it was not prepared to
listen
it has continued its massive military
buildup
and we observed and observed cyber
attacks directed against ukraine
and now russian military is moving into
ukrainian territory
by the actions and this unprovoked
military operation russia is violating
the core principles of the u.n charter
we condemn the use of force against
innocent people and the violation of the
sovereignty and territorial integrity of
ukraine in the strongest possible terms
we urge russia to terminate its military
action against ukraine immediately and
withdraw its troops mr president our
thoughts are with the ukrainian people
we will be steadfast in our support for
ukraine and our support for the u.n
charter
the russian aggression will come at an
unprecedented price politically
economically and morally
mr president france ukraine and my
country stood ready for diplomacy for
another meeting in the normandy format
or for the summit that ukraine had
proposed
with our allies and partners
we called on russia to seek a diplomatic
way forward in vain
now is the moment to speak up and defend
the international order of the u.n
charter against unilateral aggression
jointly and decisively
tonight we stand with ukraine and we are
doing so unwavering and determined thank
you mr president
i thank the representative
[Music]
thank you
in my remarks tonight i said that we
predicted
russia's false flag attacks
the misinformation
the theatrical emergency meetings and
the cyber attacks
but one piece had not come to pass
unfortunately
while we've been meeting in the security
council tonight
it appears that president putin has
ordered that last step
at the exact time
as we are gathered in the council
seeking peace
putin delivered a message of war in
total disdain
for the responsibility of this
this council
this is a grave emergency
the council will need to act
and we will put a resolution on the
table tomorrow
as president biden said tonight
russia alone is responsible for the
death and destruction this attack will
bring
and the united states and our allies and
partners will respond
in a united and decisive way
the world will hold russia
accountable
thank you
yeah
i thank the representative of the united
states
as we sat in
as we sat in this chamber urging russia
to step back
president putin announced special
military operations on ukrainian
territory
this is unprovoked and unjustified
this is a grave day for ukraine
and for the principles of the united
nations
we and our partners have been clear
that there will be consequences
for russia's
actions we fully support the united
states call for un security council
resolution
this council must do all it can
to stop the war
and uphold the charter thank you
i thank representative of the united
kingdom
of albania who also wish to make a
further statement
dear colleagues we could not end this
meeting that what we had feared and
anticipated since days
is happening
explosions are reported in kievan in
several other cities in
ukraine
mosques are finally down and tanks are
in
as we speak
russia is implementing its plan
and attacking a neighbor to whom it has
decided to deny
existence freedom
the land
dignity and life
we call on other members of the united
nations to rally in support of ukraine's
sovereignty and territorial integrity
to stand with ukraine and its people
to condemn firmly and unequivocally this
aggression
to stand for peace for rules for
international law and take whatever
measures they deem necessary to show the
aggressor that its actions will bear
consequences
let me reiterate
russia will be hold responsible for the
consequence of an unprovoked war
for the loss of human rights for causing
unbearable human pain and for opting for
destruction when we need development for
bringing death where we inspire for need
for hope
for choosing to become an outlaw when we
need cooperation
russia will bear historical blame and
shame and the consequences of invading a
neighboring country and attempting to
destroy european security
let's unite and make sure it will not
succeed
thank you
very much
and i now give the floor to the
representative of france for a further
statement
mr president mr
and for
foreign
circumstances
ireland to make a further statement
thank you mr president
when i spoke earlier i said that the
path for diplomacy and the path for
dialogue was perilously narrow
and i didn't realize in fact how
narrow and indeed how close to the
precipice we really were
just over an hour ago
we now see that that path has been
closed by the announcement of
military aggression on the part of the
russian federation against ukraine
that is something that we roundly
condemn
we stand with the people of ukraine
tonight with every man woman and child
who is seeing this news as we did as we
sat here in the chamber and whose lives
are at risk
we believe it is now time indeed for
this council
to
stand up and assume its responsibility
and to speak out in the strongest
possible terms about this
act of aggression thank you mr president
yeah
i thank representative ireland and i now
give the floor to the representative of
ukraine to make a further statement
well as i said
relinquish your duties as a chair
call putin call lavrov
to stop aggression
and i welcome the decision of
some members of this council
to meet as soon as possible to consider
the necessary decision
that would condemn the aggression
that you launch on my people
there is no purgatory for war criminals
they go straight to hell ambassador
speakers on the list this meeting is
adjourned
so
um
stick out here
ladies and gentlemen
it is the third time in a row that
russian presidency has not allowed us to
speak under the rule 37
and so as pr of estonia i am
delivering this statement here
on behalf of the baltic states latvia
lithuania and my own country estonia
we welcome and underline the urgency of
today's emergency meeting on the un
security council
the fourth over the last four weeks
to discuss the latest developments
concerning russia's further aggression
against ukraine
we thank the secretary general and under
secretary general de carlo
for their briefings
the council was convening as we witness
yet another escalatory
step as a result of a deliberate policy
of aggression by the russian leadership
and that has led us to this conflict
we
unequivocally condemn the announcement
by president putin
and the military operation in ukraine
it is unprovoked
and unlawful
act
of aggression
ukraine is facing a repeated violation
of its territorial integrity after the
illegal annexation of the autonomous
republic of crimea and the city of
sebastopol
in 2014
acts of aggression and the use of force
are violations of international law
including the u.n charter that require
accountability
we call on all u.n member states and u.n
bodies to prevent the pending war and
put a stop to the violations against the
state and people of ukraine
the request for military assistance by
moscow from the so-called people's
republics of donetsk and luhansk
announces a very dangerous additional
step against ukraine's sovereignty
it would risk thousands of lives
it follows the decision by president
putin to recognize the
non-government-controlled areas of
donetsk and luhansk oblasts of ukraine
as independent entities and the
ensuing decision to send russian troops
into these areas preceded by the
unprecedented buildup of troops on
ukraine's border
we have strongly condemned these
decisions as blatant breaches of
international law including the u.n
charter as well as of the minsk
agreements
we heard numerous similar messages of
condemnation and concern
from among countries around the world
across all regional groups at the
general assembly today
we have heard from the un secretary
general who stated that the decision of
the russian federation to recognize the
so-called independence
of the donetsk and luhansk regions is a
violation
of the territorial integrity and
sovereignty of ukraine
and inconsistent with the principles of
the charter of the united nations
it undermines the united nations itself
the u.n
should not
share the fate of the league of nations
the secretary general also made clear
his concern about the perversion of the
concept of peacekeeping
troops entering the territory of another
country without its consent are not
impartial peacekeepers
nor are they peacekeepers at all as he
pointed out
they are called invaders
yet we know today that these persistent
calls for the respect of international
law diplomacy and dialogue continued to
be unheeded
we underlined that the russian
federation's use of force against
ukraine is completely unjustified and
unacceptable
it must be met with unity firmness and
determination in solidarity with ukraine
the european union has responded to the
latest violations including with
additional restrictive measures
we stand ready to adopt more
wide-ranging political and economic
sanctions
russia's actions against ukraine are not
a matter
just for ukraine or for europe
they have severe implications globally
for every u.n member state and the
rules-based international order
we urge the russian federation as a
party to the conflict to reverse the
recognition of the so-called people's
republics
uphold its commitments abide by
international law and return to the
discussions within the normandy format
and the trilateral contact group
it has a clear responsibility on the
international law to work to find a
peaceful settlement of the conflict
we strongly urge russia to respect the
principles of the u.n charter to refrain
from any further escalatory actions
and to engage in meaningful diplomacy
we reiterate the unwavering support of
estonia latvia and lithuania for
ukraine's sovereignty independence and
territorial integrity within its
internationally recognized borders
we
the international community
stand in solidarity with ukraine
thank you
good evening the secretary general will
make some remarks and then we'll take a
few questions thank you sir
this is
the saddest moment
in my
channel
the secretary general of the united
nations
i started this meeting
of the security council
addressing
present putting
and telling him from the bottom of my
heart
stop
your troops
from
an offensive
to the ukraine give peace a chance
because too many people
have already died
during the meeting
president putin announced
a special military operation
in the donbas
and
required
the
ukrainian troops to lay down
their arms
so in the present circumstances
i must change my appeal
and i might say
present putin
in the name of humanity bring your
troops back to russia
in the name of humanity
do not allow
to start in europe
what could be
the worst war
since
the beginning of the century
with consequences
not only devastating
for
ukraine
not only
tragic
for the russian federation
but with
an
impact we can not even foresee
in relation to
their consequences for the global
economy in the moment we are when we are
emerging from the corvids
and so many developing countries
absolutely need
to have space
for the recovery which would be
very very difficult
with high prices of oil
with
the end of exports of
wheat from the ukraine
and with
rising interest rates caused by the
instability in international markets
this
conflict must stop
now
thank you very
much thank you very much mr secretary
general uh you've just talked about
consequences i wonder if you could spell
out some more what you think the
consequences would be for
will be for russia
and
for ukraine and its people
well it's clear that
military action will be
taking
it will be happening in the territory of
ukraine
and obviously
if they lead to a generalized
war
it is difficult to forecast
how dramatic it will be
in the number of people will die
in the number of people will be
displaced
in the number of people
will
lose hope in relation to the future
it is also clear
that
the consequences for the russian
federation
will be very meaningful
it's not for me to comment on sanctions
that are being implemented but it's
clear
that there'll be also
consequences
but
what is clear
for me
is that this war
doesn't make any sense
it violates
the principles of the charter
and it causes
or will cause
if it doesn't stop
a level of suffering
europe has not known
since
at least the volcanic crisis
thank you mr secretary generals pam polk
from cbs news is there anything the u.n
can do
to get russia back to the bargaining
table at this point
we can of course
in my case appeal
the security council is the body that
has
the powers can given by the charter
to address this situation
thank you very much thank you
right now
well as you
read and you heard in the
security council chamber the russian war
started against ukraine
in fact the war started in 2014.
it's a historical embarrassment to
the humanity and to this particular
organization
that has failed
to take the necessary actions
in the course of the last eight years
i demanded
in the security council that
ambassador benzo of russia relinquished
his responsibilities as a chair as the
president of security council
as a representative of a country that
egregiously
violated the charter
that he passed his duties to someone in
the security council who is capable
to perform the duties
of
the president of
the council
i'm looking forward to tomorrow's
meeting of the security council where
an appropriate draft
resolution will be put to vote
and i call to everyone
to vote in favor
the design of the united nations is
very faulty
you can ask
an aggressor
to abstain from vote
at the stage of
peaceful
resolution
on the chapter 6 but you cannot
ask aggressor believe it or not
to abstain from vote on the chapter 7
when the council deals with the
aggression
i have also asked the secretary general
of the united nations
to produce the copies of the decisions
of the security council
and the general assembly
dated 1991
that in accordance with article 4 of the
charter
welcome the desire
of the russian federation to be a member
of this organization
thank you
you were visibly emotional during this
speech um you mentioned the fact that um
most of your speech was obsolete by the
time you had the chance to read it um
what is
the message to the world at this moment
as we heard from russia the fact that an
operation a special operation in dumbass
was launched but we hear that is bombing
in explosions and kiev that special
forces from the black sea started to
enter um ukrainian territory and
and personally um what's you're feeling
you have family you have people in
ukraine right now
well they said well
if we
here in new york do not remember what
war is then go to the library
and pull out the footage
of the wall
it means thousands and thousands of
people killed if not millions
and what i want from the world i want
the world to rally after all and defend
the world from uh from the from the
aggression from the russian federation
all right it's late
we have to digest the information we
have to verify information and we have
to be here in the security council
tomorrow morning
at the end of the speech the ambassador
of russia says that this wasn't an
aggression against the ukrainian people
but in an aggression against those that
were in power do you believe that this
is a flat out
you can't be serious are you serious
you want me to
dissect the crazy lunatic semantics
of a person whose president violates the
charter whose president declared the war
and he's playing with wars
and you'd ask me to interpret it
it's lunacy
it's lunacy
absolutely
you